okay hi everyone let's get started again
okay so first of all for couple of
announcements first of all thanks to
everyone who filled in our mid-quarter
survey we actually got great
participation in that here are my two
little pac-man figures so the pac-man
figures thinks means that almost
everyone thinks the lectures at the
right pace and those that don't are
pretty much evenly divided if we go for
how challenging was assignment three
slightly more people thought it was too
easy than too hard so I guess we're
setting about rectifying that with
assignments four and five so there were
there a whole bunch of other questions
and we've been trying to absorb all the
feedback I mean one of the questions was
what people wanted most from the
remaining lectures I guess the good news
here is really we're very good at
predicting what people wanted that or
else everybody just looked ahead in the
syllabus and wrote down what it said was
ahead in the syllabus but I guess the
most popular for answers to topics that
they wanted in the remaining lectures
were transformers and bird both of which
are going to be covered this week
question answering which we talked about
last week and then text generalization
and summarization and you guys get a be
back next week to talk about that there
also a lot of people also answer this
question a different way as to what kind
of style of staff some people emphasize
new research and the latest updates from
the field I guess we'll get some of that
today as well some people were more
interested in successful applications in
industry we'll try and do a bit of that
cool new neural architectures and the
bottom answer wasn't the most popular
one I'll admit but at least a few people
wish that we were teaching more
linguistic stuff I mean that is
something that I actually feel a bit
awkward about the way things were merged
with CS 224 in with this D
I mean the truth of the matter is that
sort of seems like in the early part of
the course there's so much to cover with
neural networks backpropagation
different new Ornette architectures and
so on that the reality is that we teach
rather less linguistic stuff than we
used to in the class I mean for the last
four weeks of the class we really do try
and cover some more linguistic stuff
topics so look forward to that
announcements okay so we've made a
couple of deadline changes firstly a
number of people have mentioned that
they think after Simon five is a bit
tough and so we're giving people one
extra day to do assignment five I
realize in one sense the one extra day
is not a ton but you know there's sort
of this complex balance here because on
the other hand we don't really want to
undermine time that people have
available for final projects and if
you're one of the people who hasn't yet
started assignment five we do really
encourage you to get underway on it yeah
in the reverse direction we decided that
the project milestone was really too
late if we are going to be able to give
you feedback on it that you could
usefully make use of so in moving the
project milestone date two days earlier
and so we've also gotten everyone's
project proposals and our plan hope is
to get them back to everybody on Friday
yeah so a lot of things moving and
finally on other announcements I guess
this first day is our first invited
speaker and so if you're in person
student you're meant to be here and if
you're not able to be here you should
know about our reaction paragraph policy
and I actually stuck up on the Piazza
pin posted about reaction pieces and
attendance an example of a reaction
piece from a past class to make it a
little bit more concrete what's expected
there but you know the idea is what
we're hoping for is something that isn't
a ton of work
you can just write a hundred hundred
fifty words a few sentences but wanting
you to pick out a specific thing that
was interesting and write a couple of
sentences about what it was and what
your thoughts are about it
ie not just some very generic statement
of this was a lecture about transformers
he talked about transformers and it was
interesting that is not what we want for
the reaction piece okay so here's the
plan for today so for today's what I
want to talk about is the exciting
recent work about contextual word
representations I mean I I was thinking
of what I was going to say I was wanting
to say oh this is the most exciting
thing in deep learning for NLP in the
last five years been some since that's
completely wrong because really this is
the most exciting thing and deep
learning that happened in 2018 I mean I
guess things move very quickly in deep
learning at the moment and it's sort of
I don't think it's really fair to say
that you know it's it's got five years
of life but it's a very exciting thing
that happened last year and we'll talk
about that okay so we'll talk about
early staff ELMO on fit transformer
architectures briefly and then go on to
talk about the birth model that's been
quite prominent lately so let's just
reach let's just go backwards a bit
first to think about where we've been
and where we are now and why we might
want something more so up until now
we've sort of just had one
representation for words which is what
we learnt at the beginning of class
there was a word you trained a word
vector for it and that's what you used
in your model and you could do that with
algorithms like word defect glove or
fast text that I mentioned last week so
something on this sort of progression of
ideas in deep learning when deep
learning for NLP or the Jin general just
the resurgence of neural networks the
NLP came about sort of at the beginning
of this decade
these pre-trained word vectors so pre
trained unsupervised over a large amount
of text
they were completely seen as the secret
sauce and they were the thing that
transformed neural networks from NLP ii
to something that didn't really work to
something that worked great so this is
actually an old slide of mine so this is
a slide I guess I first made for a 2012
ACL tutorial and then sort of used in
lectures so in 2013 2014 and so this was
sort of the picture in those years so
this is looking at two tasks part of
speech tagging and named India
recognition which I'll use quite a bit
today and you know the top line was
showing a state of the art which was a
traditional categorical feature based
classifier of the kind that dominated
NLP in the 2000s decade in their
performance and what then the next line
showed is that if you took the same data
set and you trained a supervised neural
network on earth and said how good is
your performance the story was it wasn't
great perfect aim has very high numbers
always for various reasons so perhaps
the more indicative one to look at is
these named entity recognition numbers
so you know this was sort of neural net
suck right the reason why last decade
everybody used categorical feature based
Co CRF SVM kind of classify as well look
it works eight percent better than a
neural network why wouldn't anybody but
then what had happened was people had
come up with this idea that we could do
unsupervised pre-training of word
representations to come up with word
vectors for words and you know in those
days this was very hard to do the hour
because of the kind of algorithms and
the kind of machines that were available
right so Calabar and Western 2011 spent
seven weeks training their unsupervised
word representations and
the end of the day there are only a
hundred dimensional word representations
but this was the miracle breakthrough
right you put in this miracle
breakthrough of unsupervised word
representations and now the new ordinary
this going to eighty eight point eight
seven so it's almost as good as the
feature based classifier and then like
any good engineers they did some hacking
with some extra features Gazette's and
stuff like that and they got a system
that was then slightly better than the
feature based system okay so that was
sort of our picture that having these
pre trained on super unsupervised men of
word representations that was sort of
the big breakthrough and the secret
sauce that gave all the umph that made
neural networks competitive but you know
a sort of a funny thing happened which
was after people had sort of had some of
these initial breakthroughs which were
all about unsupervised methods for pre
training it was the same envision this
was the ear and vision where you're
building restricted Boltzmann machines
and doing complicated unsupervised pre
training techniques on them as well
some somehow after people had kind of
discovered that and started to get good
on it people sort of started to discover
well actually we have some new
technologies for nonlinearities
regularization and things like that
and if we keep using those same
technologies we can just go back to good
old supervised learning and shockingly
it works way better now
inside neural networks and so if you
sort of go ahead to what I'll call a
sort of 2014 to 2018 picture that the
picture is actually very different so
the pictures so these the results I'm
actually going to show this is from the
Chairman Manning neural dependency
parser that we talked about weeks ago
the picture there was you could despite
the fact that this dependency parser is
being trained on a pretty small corpus a
million words of supervised data you can
just initialize it with random word
vectors and
Craner dependency parser and to a first
approximation it just works fine you get
get further 90% accuracy English
dependency parser now it is the case
that instead you could use pre-trained
word embeddings and you do a bit better
you do about 1% better and so this was
sort of the the new world order which
was yeah these pre trained unsupervised
word embeddings are useful because you
can train them from a lot more data and
they can know about a much larger
vocabulary that means they're useful
they help with rare words and things
like that and they give you a percent
but they're definitely no longer the
sort of night and day thing to make
neural networks work that we used to
believe I'm just going to deviate here
to from the main narrative to just sort
of say one more tip for dealing with
unknown words with word vectors just in
cases useful for some people building
question answering systems right so for
sort of word vectors are unknown words
you know the commonest thing
historically is you've got your
supervised training data you define a
vocab which might be words that occur
five times or more in your supervised
training data and you treat everything
else as an UNK and so you also train one
vector for but that has some problems
which you have no way to distinguish
different UNK words either for identity
or meaning and that tends to be
problematic for question answering
systems and so one way to fix that as
what we talked about last week you could
say well words made out of characters I
can use character representations to
learn word vectors for other words and
you can certainly do that you might want
to try that that adds some complexity
but especially for things like question
answering systems there are a couple of
other things that you can do that work
considerably better and they've been
explored in this paper by Dhingra Adele
from 2017 the
one is to say well when you add test
time and count in new words probably
your unsupervised word pre-trained word
embeddings have a much bigger vocabulary
than your actual system does so anytime
you come across a word that isn't in
your vocab word embeddings just use get
the word vector of that word and start
using it that'll be a much more useful
thing to use then there's a second
possible tip that if you see something
that's still an unknown word rather than
treating a Zonk
you just assign it on the spot a random
word vector and so this has the effect
that each word does get a unique
identity which means if you see the same
word and the question and a potential
answer they will match together
beautifully in an accurate way which
you're not getting with just UNK
matching and those can be kind of useful
ideas to try okay
in digression okay so up until now we
just sort of had this representation of
words we ran word Tyvek and we got a
word vector for each word so that that
was useful this worked pretty well
but it had some big problems so what
were the big problems of doing that the
problems really of having a word back to
each word yes right so a word can hurt
so typically you have one string of
letters which has a whole bunch of
meaning so words have a ton of senses
and yet so that's the biggest the most
obvious problem that we're collapsing
together all the meanings of a word so
we talked about a bit well one solution
to that was you could distinguish words
senses and to have different word
vectors for them and I then said
something about us you could think of
this word vector as a sort of a mixture
of them and maybe a model it separated
but it seems like we might want to take
that more seriously and one way
that we could take that more seriously
is we could start to say well really you
know traditional lists of word sensors
are themselves a crude approximation
what we actually want to know is the
sense of a word inside a particular
context of use and sort of what I mean
by that is you know we distinguish
different senses of a word right so for
the word star there's the astronomical
sense and there's the Hollywood sense
and they're clearly different but you
know if we then go to this one I'm
calling the Hollywood sense I could then
say well wait a minute there are movie
stars and there are rock stars and
they're R&B stars and they're country
stars now all of those different senses
in certain contexts though one or other
of them would be a vocht and so you know
it's very hard if you're trying to
actually enumerate senses of a word as
to which one's count is different or the
same
so really you sort of wonder know what a
word means in a context there's a second
limitation of these word vectors which
is we haven't really talked about and
there's less obvious there's also
something that we might want to fix and
at least one of the models we discussed
today take some aim at that and that is
we've just sort of had one vector
forward but there are sort of different
dimensions of a word so words can have
different meanings or sort of real
semantics or words can have different
syntactic behavior like different parts
of speech or grammatical behavior so in
some sense arrive and arrival their
semantics are almost the same but
they're different parts of speech one's
a verb and one's a noun so they can kind
of appear in quite different places and
you know you'd want to do different
things with them in a dependency parser
and there are even other dimensions so
words also have register and connotation
differences so you can probably think of
lots of different words
for a bathroom and a lot of those words
all means semantically the same but have
rather different registers and
connotations as to when they're
appropriate to use and so we might want
to distinguish words on that basis as
well and so these are the kind of
solution things we want to solve with
our new contextual word embeddings so
I've said up until now you know our we
just had these word vectors that we use
words just had one vector but if you
actually think about it you know maybe
that's wrong I mean maybe we never had a
problem or at any rate we've solved as
six classes ago because if you remember
back to when we started talking about
neural language models
well what did a new language model do at
the bottom you fed into it the word
vectors but then you ran across that one
or more recurrent layers something like
an LS TM layer and was calculating these
representations that sit above each word
and you know they've all of those hidden
states is a bit ambivalent they use for
prediction they used for next hidden
state and output states and so on
but in many ways you can think huh these
representations are actually
representations of a word in context and
if you think about what happened with
the question answering systems that's
exactly how they were used right we're
an L STM's backwards and forwards over a
question and the passage and then we say
okay those are a good representation of
a words meaning in context let's start
matching them with attention functions
etc so I sort of seemed like we had
already invented a way to have context
specific representations of words and
effectively you know the rest of the
content of this lecture is sort of
basically no more complex than that that
it took a while but sort of people woke
up and started to notice huh really
funny running any language model
will you generate a context specific
representation of words maybe if we just
took those context specific
representation or words there'd be
useful for doing other things with them
and that's sort of you know there are
few more details but that's really the
summary of the entire of this lecture so
one of the first things to do that was a
paper that Matt Peters wrote in 2017 the
year before last and this was sort of a
predecessor to the sort of modern
versions of these context sensitive word
embeddings so together with co-authors
he came up with a paper called tag LM
but it essentially already had all the
main ideas so what was wanted was okay
we want to do better tasks such as named
entity recognition and what we'd like to
do is know about the meaning of a word
in context but you know standardly if we
doing named entity recognition we just
train it on half a million words of
supervised data and that's not much of a
source of information to be learning
about the meaning of words and context
so why don't we adopt a semi supervised
approach and so that's what we do so we
start off with a ton of unlabeled data
and from that unlabeled data we can
train a conventional word embedding
model like word to deck but we can also
at the same time train a neural language
models or something like bio STM
language model ok so then for step two
when we're using our supervised data
actually I guess that's step three okay
and so for then when we want to learn
our supervised power of speech tagger at
the top what we gonna do is say well for
the input words knew what york is
located we can not only use the word
embedding which is context in
pendant but we can use the our trained
recurrent language model and also run is
over this input and then we'll generate
hidden states in our bio STM language
model and we can also feed those in as
features into our our sequence tagging
model and those features will let it
work better here's a second picture that
runs this through in much greater detail
so so we're assuming that we have
trained bio STM language model for a lot
of unsupervised data then what we want
to do is we want to do named entity
recognition for New York is located so
the first thing we do is say let's just
run New Yorkers located through our
separately trained neural language model
so we run it through a four word
language model we run it through a
backward language model we get from that
a hidden state representation for each
word we can catenate the forward and
backward ones and that's going to give a
set a concatenated language model
embedding which we will use as features
in our named entity recognizer so then
for the named entity recognizer itself
that we're going to train supervised
well we have the same sentence so we can
both look up a word de Becque style
token embedding for it we can use what
we learned about with character level
cnn's and RNA ends and we can build a
character level representation for it
which we also concatenate to have two
representations so we feed these
representations into a bio STM layer but
then when we get the output of the this
bio STM layer as well as its normal
output we can concatenate with each
output what was what we get from our new
language model so
each of these things becomes a pair of
states one that's sped up from the first
BIOS DM layer and then it's concatenated
with something from the neural language
model and so that concatenated
representation is then fade into a
second layer of bio lsdm and then from
the output of that we do the usual kind
of softmax classification where we're
then giving tags like beginning of
location end of location say New York is
the location and then is we'll get an
other tag to say it's not a location so
that makes sense yeah so so the central
thing is sort of having seen that these
sort of representations that we get from
BIOS TMZ useful we're just going to feed
them into supervised models as we train
them and the idea is that will give us
better features of words some kind of
representation of their minion context
which will allow us to learn better
named empty recognizers or what idiot
whatever it is maybe I should put this
slide earlier but this slide was meant
to remind you what a named entity
recognizer is I hope you remember that
something where we're going to find and
label entities for things like person
location date organization so anyway
doing this worked so here's a little bit
of a history so the most famous named
entity recognition data set is this
connell 2003 data set which actually
exists in multiple languages but
whenever people say connell 2003 and
don't mention a language they mean the
english version of it that's the way the
world works okay so on this data said
yeah so it's sort of been around for
whatever 15 15 years roughly now so in
the so it was originally a competition
right so this in 2003 was the original
bake-off my group actually took place in
it took part in it I think we got third
or fourth place or something and now f1
score was 80
six the people who won were from IBM
research labs and they got 88 almost 89
but a difference between these two
things is our system was a single single
clean machine learning model categorical
whereas the IBM one was not only an
ensemble of four different machine
learning models plus gazetteers it also
fed in the output output of two other
old NER systems that IBM people are
trained years ago on different data so
as a I guess it worked for them but it's
a fairly complex system
here's another system from Stanford so
this was our classic Stanford NER system
that is widely used so this was then
using a conditional random field model
which generally dominated so the the
second half of the 2000s and the first
half of the 2010s for doing an ER and it
was sort of you know a bit but not
hugely better than the 2003 system this
system here was sort of the best ever
built categorical CRF system but rather
than only using the training data to
build the model as this system did it
through in Wikipedia and other stuff to
make it work better and that got to to
about ninety point eight f-16 tile
models started to be known and used in
NLP that was when people were able to
build training just on the training data
systems that worked a lot better because
essentially you're going from the same
data from this system to that system so
you're getting about four percent gain
on it because it's not wasn't making use
of Wikipedia and things like that
and so this Mar and hovey system is
pretty well known getting about ninety
1.21 okay but if we then go to this tag
um system that met Peters
Co have a system there was sort of
similar to the my own homee system but
there's a little bit worse but their
point is that this bio SDM used its re
using the newer language model is just a
useful wolf giver which sort of takes
the results up no not night and day but
slightly over a percent and then gives
them the best ner system that was then
available so that sort of proved these
sort of contextual word representations
really had some power and started to be
useful and then there's a white space at
the top because we'll get back to more
of this later there are some details on
their language model some of their
details are that it's useful to have a
bi-directional language model not
unidirectional it's useful to have a big
language model to get much in the way of
gains and you need to train this
language model over much more data it
doesn't work if you're just sort of
training it over your supervised
training data another model that was
around was Cove but I think I'll skip
that okay so then the next year Matt
Peters and a different set of colleagues
then came up with an improved system
called Elmo and effectively this was the
breakthrough system that this was sort
of just the system that everybody
noticed and said wow these contextual
word vectors are great everyone should
be using them not traditional old word
vectors yes
it's pre-trained because this piece over
here a big neural language model is
trained first and there's an important
thing I forgot to say so thank you for
the question the main reason why it's
people you know in some sense
pre-trained is this was trained first
but the the main reason why people think
of this as pre training is after you've
trained this it is frozen so this is
just something that you can run with
parameters which will give you a vector
which is your contextual word
representation each position and then
that's just going to be used in this
system so when you're training this
system there's no gradient flowing back
into this newer language model that's
changing and updating it it's just fixed
and so that's sort of the sense when
people are talking about pre training
it's sort of normally a model that you
trained somewhere else and that you're
using to give features but isn't part of
the model that you're now training yeah
I won't quite call it reconstruction
yeah it's unsupervised in the sense that
this is a language model you're training
it to predict the next word so here are
words 1 2 K what is the K plus 1
word doing a cross entropy loss and
repeat over for each position
[Applause]
yeah so I mean having gone through tag
LM in some detail I mean in some sense
the difference between tag LM and Elmo
is kind of small it's sort of in the
details I mean to a first approximation
they're doing exactly the same again but
a little bit better so I sort of hope it
made since the last time I mean what are
the things that are different they do
the bi-directional language model a bit
differently and actually one of their
concerns was to try and come up with the
compact language model that be easy for
people to use in other tasks even if
they don't have the beefiest computer
hardware in the world and so they
decided to dispense with having word
representations altogether and just use
character cnn's to build word
representations because that lessens the
number of parameters you have to store
the big matrices you have to use they
expanded the hidden dimension to 4096
but then they project it down to 512
dimensions with a sort of feed forward
projection layer and that's a fairly
common technique to again reduce the
parameterization of the model so that
you have a lot of parameters going in
their current direction but you need
much smaller matrices for including the
input at the next level
between the layers they now use a
residual connection and they do a bit of
parameter tying so it's sort of all in
the little details there but there's
another interesting thing that they did
which was an important innovation of
Elmo so we should get this bit so in tag
um what was fed from the pre-trained LM
into the main model was just the top
level of the newer language model stack
and that was completely standing de
rigueur and those
days that you might have had three
layers of newell language model but you
regard at the top level as your sort of
one that's really captured the meaning
of the sentence and the blower layers
were processing that led up to it and
they had the idea that maybe it would be
useful to actually use all layers of the
by OSD of the new language model so
maybe not just the top layer but all
layers would be kind of useful so there
are these kind of complex equations but
essentially the point of it over here is
we're going for a particular position
word seven in the language model we're
going to take the hidden state at each
level of our new language model stack
we're going to give learn a weight for
that level we're going to sort of sum
them so this is sort of a weighted
average of the hidden layers at each
position and that will be used as our
basic representation and so they found
that that gave quite a bit of extra
usefulness for and different tasks could
prefer different layers there's one
other bit here which is they learn a
global scaling factor gamma for a
particular task and this allows them to
control that for some tasks the
contextual word embeddings might be
really useful and for other tasks they
might not be so useful so you're just
sort of learning a specific usefulness
for the entire task okay so that's their
sort of new version of language model
but this this is allowing this idea of
well maybe there's sort of more
syntactic meanings of a word and more
semantic meanings of a word possibly
those could be represented different
layers of your neural language model and
then for different tasks you can
differentially weight them so that's the
basic model so you run your BIOS TM
before to get representations of each
word and then their generic elmo recipe
was well
with that frozen language model you want
to feed it into some supervised model
depending on what the task was and they
sort of say in the paper well how you do
this maybe depends on the task you might
want to kind of concatenate it to an
intermediate layer just as the tag LM
did that might be fine but you know it
might also be useful to make use of
these Elmo representations when
producing outputs so if you're doing
something like generation system or you
might just sort of feed in the ELMO
representation again be before you sort
of do the softmax to find the output
they sort of left it flexible as to how
it was used but the general picture you
know was kind of like we saw before
indeed I'm reusing the same picture that
you've calculated an Elmo representation
from for each position as a weighted
average and then you're sort of
concatenated that to the hidden state of
your supervised system and generating
your output anyway
one way or another they were able to do
this and with the little improvements
that gave them about an extra point
three percent in named entity
recognition now that sort of sounds like
not very much and you might conclude
from this why the excitement and you
know in some sense that's right because
sort of to the extent that there was an
interesting idea here really they'd come
up with it for the tag um paper which
gave a much better gain but you know why
everyone got really excited was that in
the ELMO paper they then showed this
isn't something that you can do one-off
to improve a named entity recognizer
you can take these Elmo representations
and use them for pretty much any NLP
task and they can be very useful and
give good gains and so essentially why
people got excited was because of the
data that's in this table so here we're
taking a whole bunch of very different
tasks so there's squad question
answering
there's natural language in France
there's semantic role labeling there's
coreference the named entity recognition
doing sentiment analysis so a wide range
of different NLP tasks and that they
have a previous state of the art system
they produce their own baseline which is
you know commonly sort of similar to the
previous state of the art but usually
actually a bit worse than the current
state of the art because it's whatever
simply in a system that they came up
with but then they could say in each
case I'll just take this system and add
ELMO vectors into the hidden
representations in the middle and have
those help you predict and in general in
all cases that's giving you about a 3%
or so gain absolute which was then
producing this huge performance increase
which in all cases was moving the
performance well above the previous
state of the art system so you know this
sort of then made it seem like magic
pixie dust because you know in the
stakes of NLP conference land you know a
lot of people used to trying to come up
with a paper for the next year that's
one percent better on one task and
writing it up and that's their big
breakthrough this for the year to get
their new paper out and the idea that
there's just well this set of this way
of creating context sensitive word
representations and you just use them in
any task and they'll give you around 3%
and take you past the state of the art
this seemed like it was really great
stuff and so people got very excited
about this in a won best paper award at
the napkin or 2018 conference and then
as I sort of vaguely mentioned so the
model that they actually used wasn't a
deep stack there are actually two layers
of bio STM's but they do show this
interesting resolved that the lower
level better captures low level syntax
word properties and there's most useful
things like part-of-speech taking
syntactic dependencies NER where the top
layer of their language model is better
for higher-level semantics and there's
more useful for things like sentiment
semantic role labeling and question
answering so that seemed interesting
though I've actually been interesting to
see how that panned out more if you had
sort of more layers to play with okay
Elmo done so moving right ahead here's
something else that I just thought I
should mention a little bit about
another piece of work that came out
around the same time a few months later
maybe well maybe not came out around the
same time in in 2018 was this work on
universal language model fine-tuning the
text classification or on fit by Howard
and ruder and essentially this had the
same general idea of saying well what we
want to do is transfer learning where we
can learn a big language model a big
language model and then for our target
tasks which might be named in
recognition but here is text
classification we can transfer this
language model information and help us
to do better with the tasks and so they
proposed an architecture to do that and
so their architecture was you have a big
unsupervised corpus from which you train
a new language model they used a deeper
new language model with three hidden
layers you then fine-tune your new
language model on the actual domain that
you're interested in working in so this
was sort of an extra stage that they did
and then finally you've now introduced
your classification objective so what
they're going to be doing is making text
classifiers so we're now wanting to take
this model and turn it from a language
model into a text class
fire but there is something that they
did differently which is in some sense
foreshadows the later work in
transformers so rather than just feeding
features from this into a completely
different network they keep using the
same network but they introduce a
different objective at the top so one
thing you could do with this network is
use it to predict the next word as a
language model and so at this point they
freeze the parameters of that softmax at
the top that's why it's shown in black
but instead they could stick on a
different prediction unit where it's
predicting stuff for a particular task
so it might be predicting positive or
negative sentiment in a text
classification task or something like
that so in their model they're sort of
reusing the same Network but sticking on
the top of it a different layer to do
their new classification tasks they were
also interested in something small the
sort of one GPU model of research the
paper has a lot of detail as sort of
tricks and care and feeding of your
neural models to maximize performance if
you're interested in that you could sort
of look up some of the details about
that but what they were able to show
again was making use of this language
model pre-training was a very effective
way to improve performance this time for
text classification so these are text
classification and data sets IMDB is for
sentiment trek is the topical text
classification and again there are
preceding systems that other people have
developed and they're showing that by
making use of this language model
pre-training they're able to
significantly improve on the state of
the art so these are error rates so that
low is good they also showed another
interesting result which is kind of what
you would expect or hope from doing this
kind of transfer learning that what they
were able to show is if you can train
this neural language model on a beer
amount of data that that means you'll
then be able to do well on your
supervised tasks even when trained on
pretty little data so here this is error
rate so low is good and so what that and
here's the number of training examples
which is being done on a log scale and
so the blue line is if you're just
training a text classifier from scratch
on supervised data so you need a lot of
data to start to do pretty well but if
you're making use of this transfer
learning from pre trained language model
you can get to that you're sort of doing
pretty well with way less training
examples essentially an order of
magnitude less training examples will
give you the same amount of performance
and the difference between these two
lines corresponds to the extra phase
that they had in the middle of theirs
which is whether you're doing this sort
of extra fine-tuning on your target
domain as part of your process and they
found that to be pretty helpful okay so
that is another precursor and so one big
part of what has happened since then is
effectively people said this is a good
idea maybe it'll become a really really
good idea
if we just make things way bigger so
OMPH it was something that you could
train in one GPU day sounds appealing
for CS 224 in final projects remember
that and but well then the people at
open AI decided well we could build a
pre trained language model and train it
on a much larger amount of data on a
much larger amount of compute and use
about 240 GPU days and that will get a
lot better and it did and then the
people at Google said well we could
train a model into 256
pee-yew days which means maybe about
double the amount of computation it's
hard to figure out exactly and that
might be able to do exciting things and
that was the bird model and it did and
then if you're following along these
things just last week the open AI people
said well we can go much bigger again
and we can train a model for
approximately 2,000 TPU version three
days and it will be able to do much
bigger again a bit much better again and
so this is this GP to GPT two language
model which open AI released last week
and there are certain there are actually
very impressive results when they're
showing that if you're sort of building
a really really huge language model over
a very large amount of data and then you
say language model go off and generate
some text honest particular topic that
it can actually just do a great job of
producing text so the way this was being
done was a human is writing a couple of
sentences in a shocking finding
scientists discovered a herd of unicorns
living in a remote previously unexplored
valley in the Andes Mountains and so
we're then using our neural language
model and chugging through that so that
gives us us context and then say
generate more text and it starts to
generate the scientists named the
population after their distinctive horn
over its unicorn these four horns silver
white uniforms were previously unknown
to science it produces remarkably good
text or at least in the in the
hand-picked examples that they showed in
the tech news it produces extremely good
text yeah so I think one should be a
little bit cautious about that and sort
of some of its random outputs actually
aren't nearly as good but nevertheless
you know I think it is actually dramatic
how good language models are becoming
once you're training them all
long context as we can do with modern
models on vast amounts of data so then
the open AI people decide this language
model was so good that they weren't
going to release it to the world which
then got transformed into headlines of
Elon Musk's open AI bills artificial
intelligence so powerful and must be
kept locked up for the good of humanity
with the suitable pictures that always
turn up at these moments down the bottom
of the screen and yeah I guess that was
it leading even Elon Musk to be wanting
to clarify and say that it's not
actually really that he's directing
what's happening and open AI anymore
anyway
moving right along so part of the story
here is just a scaling thing that these
things have been getting bigger and
bigger but the other part of the story
is that all three of these are then
systems that use a transformer
architecture and transformer
architectures have not only been very
powerful but technically of a loud
scaling to much bigger sizes so to
understand some of the rest of these we
should learn more about transformers and
so I'm sort of going to do that but I
mean in mix of orders our invited
speaker coming Thursday as one of the
authors of the transformer paper and is
going to talk about transformers so I
think what I'm going to do is say a
little bit about transformers quickly
and not really dwell on all the details
but hope that it's a bit of an
introduction and you can find out more
on Thursday about the details and then
talk some more about the Burt model
before finishing so the motivation for
transformers is essentially we want
things to go faster so we can build
bigger models and the problem as we
mentioned for these lsdm or in general
any of the recurrent models is the fact
that they're occurring
you have to generate sort of wonder
hints status time chugging through and
that means you just can't do the same
kind of parallel computation that GPUs
love that you can do in things like
convolutional neural networks but you
know on the other hand we discovered
that even though these gated recurrent
units like LST M's and Gi use a great
that to get really great performance out
of these recurrent models we found that
we wanted to we had a problem with them
these long sequence lengths and we can
improve things by adding attention
mechanisms and so that led to the idea
of well sense attention works so great
maybe we can just use attention and we
can actually get rid of the recurrent
part of the model altogether and so that
actually then leads to the idea of these
transformer architectures and the
original paper on this is actually
called attention as all you need which
reflects this idea of we're going to
keep the attention part and we're
getting it going to get rid of the
recurrent part and we'll be able to
build a great model so in the initial
work what they're doing is machine
translation kind of like the neuro
machine translation with attention we
described but what they wanting to do is
build a complex encoder and a complex
decoder that works non recurrently and
nevertheless is able to translate
sentences well by making use of lots of
attention distributions and so I wanted
to say a little bit more quickly about
that and hopefully we'll get more of
this on Thursday first as a as a
recommended resource if you want to look
at home and learn more about the
transformer architecture there's this
really great bit of work by sasha rush
called the annotated transformer that
goes through the entire transformer
paper accompanied by PI torch code
in a Jupiter notebook and so that can
actually be a really useful thing but
I'll go through a little bit of the
basics now of how we do things so the
basic idea is that they're going to use
attention everywhere to calculate things
and we talked before about the different
kinds of attention of the sort of
multiplicative by linear attention and
the little feed for network additive
attention they kind of go for the
simplest kind of attention where the
attention is just dot products between
two things but they sort of do the more
comp for various purposes they do the
more complicated version of dot product
between two things where they have when
the things that they're looking up are
assumed to be key value pairs keys and
values and so you're calculating the
similarity as a dot product between a
query and the key and then based on that
you're going to be using the vector for
the corresponding value so our equation
here for what we're calculating is where
you looking using the softmax / query
key similarities and using that to give
the waiting's as an attention based
weighting over the corresponding values
so that's the basic attention model so
that saying it that way adds a little
bit of complexity but sort of for the
simplest part for their encoder actually
all of the query keys and values are
exactly the same they're the words that
they're using as their source language
things so it sort of adds some
complexity that isn't really there okay
I'll skip that so there are a couple of
other things that they do one thing that
they note is that the the value should
get from huge
kay very invariances the dimension gets
large so that they sort of do some
normalization by the size of the hidden
state dimension but I'll leave that out
as well for details right so in the
encoder everything is just our word
vectors they're the queries the keys and
the values and we're going to use
attention everywhere in the system
whoops okay so the second new idea is
well attention is great but maybe it's
bad if you only have one attention
distribution because you can only attend
to things one way maybe for various
users would be great if you could attend
from one position to various things so
if you're thinking about syntax and what
we did with dependency parsers if you're
a word you might want to attend to your
head word but you might also want to
attend attend to your dependent words
and if you happen to be a pronoun you
might want to attend to what the pronoun
refers to you might want to have lots of
attention so they introduced this idea
of multi-head attention and so what
you're doing with multi-head attention
is you have your hidden States in your
system and you map them by projection
layers which are just multiplications by
different W matrices as linear
projections into sort of different lower
dimensional spaces and then you use each
of those to calculate dot product
attention and so you can attend to
different things at the same time and
this multi-head attention was one of the
very successful ideas of transformers
that made them a more powerful
architecture ok so then for our complete
transformer block it's sort of then
starting to build complex architectures
like we sort of started seeing the other
week so ok yeah so starting from our
word vectors we kind of going to do
attention to multiple different things
and we're simultaneously going to have a
residual connection that's short
circuits around them we're then going to
sort of sum the two of these and then
they're going to do a normalization at
that point I talked previously about
batch normalization they don't do batch
normalization they do another variant
which is layer normalization which is a
different way of doing normalization but
I'll skip that for now and then they
sort of for one Transformer block you
then go after the multi-head attention
you put things through a feed-forward
layer which also has a residual
connection you sum the output of those
and you then again do another layer
normalization so this is their basic
transformer block that they're going to
use everywhere and to make their
complete architectures they're then
going to sort of start stacking these
transformer blocks to produce a very
deep network and in some sense what has
been found is that transformers perform
very well but you know there's no free
lunch you kind of can't you know now no
longer getting recurrent information
actually being carried along a sequence
you've got a word at some position which
can be casting attention on other words
so if you'd like to have information
carried along in a chain you've sort of
first of all got to walk the first step
of the chain and then you need to have
another layer vertically which can walk
the next step of the chain and then you
need to have another layer vertically
that walks the next step of the chain so
you're getting rid of the recurrence
along the sequence but you're
substituting some depth to allow things
to walk along multiple hops and
nevertheless that's highly advantageous
and GPU architectures because it allows
you to use parallelization to calculate
everything at each depth at the same
time
hmm maybe I'll go light on explaining
this as well so they're used by parent
coatings but if you do nothing else you
just have words fed in as word vectors
and you have no idea whether you're at
the beginning of the sentence or at the
end of the sentence though they have a
message method of doing positional
encoding which gives you some ideas that
position your word has in the sentence
okay
so that's sort of the encoder system so
from the words they have an initial word
embedding you add in their positional
encoding you go into one of these
transformer blocks and you then repeat
it in time so you'll have a stack of
these transform of blocks so your
multiple times doing multi-head
attention to other parts of the sentence
calculating values feeding forward a
value putting it through a fully
connected layer and then you just sort
of repeat due attention to different
places in the sentence get all your
information put it through a fully
connected layer and go up proceeding up
deeply and and that sounds a little
mysterious but it turns out to work just
great and the way to think about I think
is that at each stage you can look with
your multi-headed attention at various
other places in the sentence accumulate
information push it up to the next layer
and if you do that sort of half a dozen
times you can be starting to
progressively push information along the
sequence in either direction to
calculate values that are of interest
and the interesting thing is that these
models turn out to work really well it's
sort of learning to attend of
interesting things in linguistic
structure so these are just sort of
suggestive diagrams but this is looking
at layer five of a transformer stack and
seeing what words are being attended to
by different attention heads so these
different colors correspond to different
and heads and so the sentence is it is
in this spirit that a majority of
American governments have passed new
laws since 2009 making the registration
or voting process more difficult and so
what we see is sort of most of the
attention heads looking for making to
making more difficult and that seems to
be useful one of the attention head
seems to be looking at the word itself
might be okay then the other ones are
sort of looking a bit at laws and at
2009 so it's sort of picking out the
arguments and modifiers of making in the
syntax kind of like way interestingly
for pronouns attention heads appear to
learn to be able to look back to
reference so the law will never be
perfect but its application should be
just that one attention head it for its
is looking at what it's is modifying the
application but another attention head
but it's is looking strongly at what
it's refers back to as the law so that
seems kind of cool yeah okay and so then
for the rest of their model there's then
some more complexity for how to use the
Transformers decoder to give you a full
new or machine translation system but I
think maybe I will skip that and go on
and say a bit about but in my remaining
minutes okay so the latest and greatest
contextual word representations to help
you for your tasks have been these Bert
vectors where bird is bi-directional
encoder representation turns from
transformers and so essentially it's
using the encoder from a transformer
Network I this deep multi header
detention stack to calculate a
representation of a sentence and saying
that's a great all /
representation of a sentence that you
can use for tasks be it named entity
recognition or squad question-answering
and so there's actually an interesting
new idea that these people had and that
while their idea was world standard
language models a unidirectional and
that's useful because it gives you a
probability distribution a language
model but it's bad because you'd like to
be able to do prediction from both sides
to understand word minion context
there's a second choice which is you can
kind of do bi-directional models when
you incorporate information in both ways
but that sort of has problems as well
because then you get cross talk and so
if you run a bios TM and then you merge
the representations by concatenation and
then feed them into the next layer when
you're running the next layer the Ford
LS TM will have already gone information
about the future from the first layer so
it's sort of ends up with words are
already seeing the future and themselves
so you have this sort of complex non
generative model so somehow they wanted
to do things a bit differently so they
can have bi-directional context without
words being able to see themselves and
the idea that they came up with is well
we're going to train things with the
transformer encoder but what we're gonna
do is mask out some of the words in the
sentence like maybe we'll mask here
store and gallon and then so our
language model our language modeling
like objective will no longer be a true
language model that's sort of generating
a probability of a sentence which is
standardly done by working from left to
right but it'll stead be a mad libs
style fill-in-the-blank objective so
you'll see this context which will be
literally the man went to the master by
a mask of milk and your what your
training of
active is to say try and predict what
this word is which you can do with a
cross entropy loss to the extent that
you don't get store and then it will be
try and guess what this word is and you
want to let guess gallon so you're
training a model to fill in these blanks
and the rate at which they blank words
is essentially one word and seven and
they discuss how this is a trade-off
because if you blank to few words it
gets very expensive to train and if you
blank many words
well you've blanked out most of the
context of a word and that means it's
not very useful for training and they
found there out sort of one in seven
seemed to work pretty well for them but
what they want to argue is that for the
open a eyes GPT which is also transform
a model it's a sort of a classic
language model working from left to
right and so you only get left context
for the bird language model sorry the
ELMO language model that's shown up at
the top well they're running a
left-to-right language model and they're
running a right to left language model
so in some sense they have context from
both sides but these two language models
are trained completely independently and
then you just sort of concatenating
their representations together so
there's no sense in which are actually
kind of having a model that's jointly
using context from both sides at the
time though that the pre trained
contextual word representations are
built so their hope is using inside a
transformer model this trick of blanking
out words and predicting it using the
entire context will allow them to use
two sided context and be much more
effective and that's what they seem to
show there's one other complication and
I mean I'll show later this last
complication is a bit useful and it's
sort of not really essential to their
main eye
was that they thought one of the one of
the goals in their head was clearly to
be able to have this be useful for
things like question answering tasks or
natural language inference tasks and
their relationships between two
sentences so their idea was well one
good objective is this fill in the blank
word objective which is sort of like a
language modeling objective but they
thought it'd be useful to have a second
objective where you're predicting
relationships between sentences so they
secondly have a loss function which is
let's have two sentences where the
sentences might be two successive
sentences in a text or a sentence
followed by a random sentence from
somewhere else and we want to train the
system to predict when you've been
seeing an correct next sentence versus a
random sentence and so you're also
training a loss based on this next
sentence prediction tasks and so it'll
be something like the man went to the
store he bought a gallon of milk you
meant to predict true is next sentence
the man went to the store penguins are
flightless you meant to say false this
isn't a next sentence and so they're
simultaneously also training with this
representation so what they end up looks
looks like this so they have for the
input they'll have a pair of sentences
my dog is cute separator he likes
playing the words are represented as
word pieces like we talked about last
week so there's a token embedding for
each word piece then there's a
positional embedding for each word piece
which is going to be summed with the
token embedding and then finally there's
a segment embedding for each word piece
we're just simply whether it comes from
the first sentence or the second
sentence before or after the separator
so you're summing those three things
together to get the token
representations and then you're going to
use
in a transformer model where you will
have losses to the extent that you can't
predict the mast words and then your
binary prediction function as to whether
it's a correct next sentence or not
which is the training architecture okay
so it's a transformer as before
it's trained on Wikipedia plus the book
corpus and they built two models the
base Burt model was a 12 layer
transformer and so this correspondent of
what the previous transformer paper had
used right those two layer transformer
blocks repeated six times gave you 12
layers with 768 hints dimension hidden
states and 12 heads from the multi-head
attention and then they went bigger and
trained Bert large which is sort of
double the number of layers bigger
hidden states even more attention heads
and training these on quads of TP use so
first of all your training on this basis
for masked words and next sentence or
not
so then what they wanted to say was this
pre trained model evaluated on these
losses of masked language model next
sentence prediction we could then take
this model freeze most of its what we
know sorry that's wrong we could take
this model pre trained and it would be
incredibly useful for various different
tasks we had use it for named entity
recognition question answering natural
language inference etc and the way we're
going to do it is kind of doing the same
thing as the own fit model did we're not
just going to say here's our here's a
contextual word representation like Elmo
did instead we what we're going to say
is just keep on using this pre keep on
using this transformer network that we
trained as a sort of language model but
fire
into net for a particular task so you're
now going to run this transformer
calculating representations for a
particular task and the what we're going
to change is we're going to remove the
very top level prediction the bits that
predict the masked language model and
next sentence prediction and we're going
to substitute on it on top a final
prediction layer that's appropriate for
the task
so if our task is squad question
answering our final prediction layer
will be predicting start of span and end
of span kind of like when we saw dr. QA
a couple of weeks ago if what we're
doing is the NE our task our final
prediction layer will be predicting the
natural named entity recognition class
of each token just like a standard NER
system okay
and so they built this system and tested
it on a whole bunch of data sets one of
the main things they tested on was this
glue data set which it has a whole bunch
of tasks a lot of the tasks their
natural language inference task I've
kept saying that phrase all this lecture
but I haven't really defined it so if a
natural language inference you're given
two sentences like hills and mountains
are especially sanctified in jainism and
then you can run a hypothesis 'm Jainism
hates nature and what you're meant to
say is whether the hypothesis follows
from the premise contradicts the premise
or has no relation to the premise so
it's a three-way classification and so
here it contradicts the premise there
are various other tasks such as this
linguistic acceptability task but if we
look at these Glu tasks these are
showing the pre open AI state-of-the-art
how well Elmo works how well open a eyes
GPT works and then how well the small
and large burt models work and
effectively what you're finding is
that the open AI GPT was all you know
pretty good
it showed actually good advances on most
of these tasks for many but not all of
them have broke the previous state of
the art showing the power of these
contextual language models but the
bi-directional form of Bert's prediction
just seem much better again
so going from this line to this line
you're getting depending on the task
about two percent better performance and
so the bird people actually did their
experiments carefully so these models
are pretty comparable in terms of size
but the bi-directional context seems to
really help and then what they found was
well by going to just a bigger model
again you could get another big lift in
performance and so you're getting for
many of the tasks about another two
percent lift and performance going to
the bigger model so this really produced
super strong results and in general some
people have found that Bert continues to
give super strong results so if I return
back to my Connell any our tasks we had
Elmo giving you ninety two point two and
you sort of continue to get gains a Bert
base gets you to ninety two point four
and Bert large takes you to ninety two
point eight though in truth in truth and
description there is now system at beats
Bert large on NER which is actually a
character level transform a language
model from flair but you know this
continued over to a lot of other things
so on squad one point one Bert
immediately just outperformed everything
else that people been working on for
squad for ages in particular what was
especially dramatic was the singer
single Bert model beat everything else
that had been done previously on squad
version 1.1 even though they could also
show that ensemble of Bert models could
give further good performance gains and
as I mentioned before essentially if you
look at the squad 2.0 leaderboard
all of the top-ranked systems are using
Bert one place or another and so that
sort of led into this sort of new world
order that okay it seems like the state
of NLP now is to if you want to have the
best performance you want to be using
these deep pre-trained transformer
stacks to get the best performance and
so this is sort of making NLP more like
vision because really vision for five
years has had these deep pre-trained
your network stacks like resonates where
from most vision tasks what you do is
you take a pre trained ResNet and then
you find Chu in a layer at the top to do
some classification tasks you're
interested in and this is sort of now
starting to be what's happening in NLP
as well that you can do the same thing
by downloading your pre trained Bert and
fine-tuning it to do some particular
performance tasks okay that's it for
today and more on transformers on
Thursday